[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magazine de informativos 100%
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre es liliana valencia que damos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
sudáfrica es el país africano más
afectado por el coronavirus y un tercio
de su población tiene problemas de
sobrepeso está realidad toma mayor
relevancia en el contexto de la pandemia
de ccoo del 19 dado que estos pacientes
tienden a sufrir mayores complicaciones
durante un contagio u hospitalización
un artista nigeriano puso su talento al
servicio de quienes necesitan una
prótesis crea extremidades artificiales
recubiertas con un material que simula
la piel humana negra con el objetivo de
que los africanos no se vean obligados a
usar prótesis de un color más claro que
el de su propia piel
y la crisis económica mundial afecta
directamente a los productores de cacao
de costa de márfil quienes han visto
caer sus precios debido a la baja
demanda este país es el primer productor
de cacao del mundo y los agricultores
piden soluciones al gobierno
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días con más de
30.000 muertes y más de un millón de
contagios sudáfrica es el país más
afectado por el coi 19 en el continente
africano el gobierno espera vacunar al
70% de la población durante los próximos
meses utilizando grupos de riesgo
incluidas las personas que sufren de
obesidad un tercio de los hombres y dos
tercios de las mujeres sudafricanas
tienen problemas de sobrepeso nuestros
corresponsales nos cuentan esta historia
el sudafricano promedio eso es una
realidad que se reviste de complejidad
en el marco de la pandemia de kobe 19
aquellos que hacen parte de esta
población se han visto afectados de
manera desproporcionada por el virus que
golpea al país los investigadores están
explorando el porqué en la universidad
de petronio este profesor no se explicó
que el sobrepeso puede dañar el sistema
inmunológico lo que hace que sea más
fácil contraer el kobe y aún más
superarlo
y las personas con obesidad tenían dos
veces más probabilidades de ser
hospitalizadas debido a la gravedad de
su enfermedad respecto a las personas
que no eran obesas y también encontraron
que había un 50% más de probabilidades
de mortalidad ya provel etim of mucha
leche la diabetes y la hipertensión
enfermedades relacionadas con la
obesidad también son factores de riesgo
las personas con sobrepeso de sudáfrica
ahora están siendo priorizadas para la
vacunación contra el coronavirus como
grupo vulnerable
creo que todo el mundo tiene una
sensación de ansiedad personal y
desearían saber en qué momento estaremos
a salvo y 26 algunas personas con
obesidad en el país han luchado por
perder peso durante el confinamiento sin
embargo la mayoría al aumento en 2020
según el último informe liderado por una
empresa de alimentos del país afirmando
que los hábitos alimenticios de muchos
han empeorado
y así pudimos trazar un mapa exacto de
lo que la gente estaba comiendo más de
esto menos de aquello y el problema que
encontramos es la sal las personas
consumían mucha más sal de la
recomendada y también bocadillos
entonces lo que me sorprendió en
particular fue el tamaño de la porción
lo que la gente sintió como una porción
normal y más saludable era demasiado
grande
y pudo ser
y la obesidad es un problema de salud
pública abordarlo seriamente podría
ayudar a la lucha contra el kobe 19
seguimos hablando de salud porque un
artista nigeriano está creando prótesis
para personas que hayan perdido alguna
de sus extremidades sus creaciones
buscan asemejarse a las partes reales
del cuerpo y están recubiertas con un
material que simula la piel oscura
predominante en el continente africano
wow esto es encantador guau finalmente
tengo mis dedos de regreso increíble
michael está feliz con su nueva mano
derecha una prótesis similar a un guante
de silicona que le ayudará a volver a su
vida normal después de perder tres dedos
en un accidente automovilístico hace un
año esta prótesis tiene una sensación
hiper realista y lo mejor combina a la
perfección con su color de piel
acan realmente me ha ayudado porque
puedo seguir con mi vida normal sin
esconder mis manos o sin miedo a la
discriminación oa la compasión hans a
el artista detrás de esta creación el
john aman a un joven de 32 años experto
en efectos especiales y arte cosmético
para las prótesis realizó un molde de
yeso y mezclo pinturas en una paleta
buscando el tono de piel adecuado
su objetivo es fabricar prótesis con
colores de pieles diversos para brindar
seguridad a los pacientes que las usen
white en el ifai tenemos prótesis hechas
de piel blanca
rara vez encuentras personas con
prótesis de piel negra así que quiero
hacerlas para los negros
quiero que áfrica tenga una sensación
que esté más cerca de resolver esta
necesidad dentro de áfrica quiero llegar
a los negros en todo el mundo también
para que ellos puedan acceder a este
tipo de prótesis asesino al agua de
burgess
a mano tiene una formación profesional
en la fabricación de prótesis pero
estudió escultura afirma que las
personas que las usan podrán regresar a
su vida normal pero que deben tener
ciertos cuidados para protegerlas y
mantenerlas por más tiempo
lágrimas que puedes usarla durante mucho
tiempo porque son como la piel humana la
piel humana necesita cuidados a estas
pero es decisión son carnosas y por eso
reaccionan a ciertos estímulos como el
tacto hay que tener cuidado estas son
algunas de las cosas sobre las que nos
tomamos nuestro tiempo para que los
clientes aprendan a cuidar la anchura
su empresa arte cosmética inmortal es
parte de una creciente industria de
servicios que ha ayudado a que la
economía de nigeria se convierta en la
más grande de áfrica las piezas se
venden por lo menos a 40.000 nairas lo
que equivale alrededor de 111 dólares
y vamos a acostar martín porque cada dos
años se realiza en la villa en el
mercado de artes del espectáculo massa
catalogado como el más grande del
continente africano el más reúne música
moda danza humor y muchos otros formatos
que encuentran en este espacio la
plataforma de difusión y circulación
justamente en el continente africano la
nueva edición está programada para marzo
de 2022 y ahora las convocatorias están
abiertas a artistas africanos y de la
diáspora mundial pueden postularse hasta
el 31 de julio la directora de
comunicaciones del festival es sophie
kuruma nos entregó detalles desde abiyán
él massa el mercado de artes y del
espectáculo de abiyán es un programa
internacional de desarrollo de las artes
vivas creado en 1990 por el ministerio
de cultura y de la francofonía su
objetivo es reforzar la capacidad de los
profesionales africanos de las artes
vivas y también favorecer el acceso de
la producción artística africana en el
mercado internacional por eso ahora
después de 11 ediciones el massa recibe
cada dos años porque es una bienal
durante una semana a los artistas y
profesionales que vienen de todo el
mundo podemos decir que es a la vez una
bolsa para el espectáculo y también un
forum de intercambio y un festival muy
popular es una plataforma de difusión de
promoción de distribución y de formación
de las artes vivas la próxima edición se
realizará del 5 al 12 de marzo de 2022
en abiyán para participar los artistas y
grupos artísticos de las disciplinas
siguientes arte cirse arte circense y
marionetas cuento danza moda música
humor slam arte callejero visual y
teatro podrán presentar su candidatura
en la página web del más a
y punto y para hacerlo tienen hasta el
31 de julio de 2021 después en
septiembre de 2021 los miembros del
comité artístico internacional compuesto
por expertos y profesionales de todas
las disciplinas presentes en el masa se
reunirán y procederán a la selección de
los grupos artísticos que serán
invitados a participar en 2022 en uno de
los festivales más grandes de áfrica
seguimos en costa de márfil porque la
escasa demanda mundial de cacao ha
provocado represamientos de este grano
en los principales puertos de ese país
dejando pérdidas para miles de
productores y ralentizando la cosecha
principal desde mediados de diciembre
los agricultores atraviesan por una
profunda crisis y piden soluciones al
gobierno
miles de toneladas de cacao
consumiéndose en almacenes y
contenedores
en costa de márfil la industria del
chocolate está soportando la peor parte
de la desaceleración económica global
causada por la pandemia durante los
últimos meses ha sido casi imposible
para los productores de cacao vender su
producto muchos estudiantes se quedaron
en las calles porque sus padres no
encontraban compradores para su cacao
por lo cual no tenían dinero para enviar
a sus hijos a la escuela exportadores
marfileños de cacao dicen que los
principales fabricantes de chocolate de
eeuu y europa
vivieron recientemente posponer las
entregas por tres meses citando una
demanda global reducida además el precio
mínimo de compra de mil francos un kilo
establecido por las autoridades de costa
de marfil en octubre del año pasado para
ayudar a sacar los productos de la
pobreza ahora pueden tener el efecto
contrario los que ustedes tenemos
problemas porque los compradores que
vienen aquí dicen que no pueden pagar
los mil francos y venderlos a los
compradores libaneses por el mismo
precio solo obtendrán ganancias si nos
pagan 900 o 950 francos dfa desde 2019
cosa de marfil y ghana los dos mayores
productores de cacao del mundo han
emitido una serie de medidas conjuntas
para apoyar a los agricultores locales
pero hasta ahora estos han tenido un
impacto limitado en la industria sólo el
6 por ciento de la riqueza producida
llega a manos de los agricultores y
productores continuamos en túnez atrás
de la crisis del sector de los fosfatos
se ha dejado sin un proyecto de vida a
miles de jóvenes organizaciones sociales
tratan de promover el empleo a veces con
la ayuda del gobierno
estas imágenes son muy comunes desde
2011 en redeyef en el suroeste de túnez
se ha detenido la producción de fosfato
después de una foca western digital soy
yo como entidad el desempleo sigue
aumentando así como la espera de las
decisiones del gobierno
desde la revolución el empleo de los
jóvenes sigue siendo un problema para el
gobierno la tasa de desempleo para las
personas entre los 15 y 25 años es del
36% para responder a esta demanda social
durante la votación del presupuesto 2021
el parlamento aprobó una ley que prevé
la contratación de 10 mil jóvenes
licenciados que han estado desempleados
durante más de 10 años haykel fundó su
empresa de seguridad y mantenimiento
la revolución me dio una oportunidad
porque en 2018 cuando empecé mi negocio
acababa de aprobarse la nueva ley de
presupuesto de tickets sobre cómo ésta
daba muchas ventajas a las pequeñas
empresas o utilice jiang
y otros jóvenes cuestionan los problemas
estructurales y políticos de la economía
cliente lista heredada de la dictadura
la organización alerta está produciendo
un programa en youtube para concientizar
a la opinión pública tunecina sobre el
problema de la economía de renta
que es la renta
son esencialmente bloqueos en la
economía esos bloqueos no tienen
justificación para seguir el bien común
es cuando permitimos que ciertos actores
tengan privilegios pero que no
beneficien a todos los tunecinos ante
ese balance el país se encuentra hoy en
día en un punto de inflexión en su
transición democrática las exigencias de
la revolución la justicia social el
empleo y la dignidad están siempre
presentes y finalizamos con música que
nos llega desde guinea ecuatorial donde
el artista damon está presentando su
nueva canción titulada colm y los
dejamos con un saludo que lo envía a la
audiencia de áfrica siete días desde
malabo y con imágenes de su nuevo vídeo
cristian con más en france 24 punto com
soy tengo una cara artista de guinea
ecuatorial y del sello los juntos de
music vengo a presentar mi nuevo video
tiene por título como en el programa
african siete días y en el canal
franklin pero que lo disfruten al cloud
yo te calientes y te hace frío soy indio
maní cantante ayer pero tú lo sabes que
yo soy tu magia te hago porros y buen
rollo con los colosos los vivos
solo me dices
[Música]
picante
cuando estés en el estado con los más
fondos
sólida solo me explicas cómo es la cosa
y así nace completar me da señal cuando